you
[Music]
okay let's get started thanks for coming
to today's Microsoft Research AI
distinguished lecture it's an honor
today to have Michael Kern's with us
Michael is Professor and the National
Center chair in the computer and
information science department at the
University of Pennsylvania you also have
as appointments in the Economics
Department and at the Wharton School of
Business he's the founding director of
pens Warren Center for networking data
Sciences
he's as you all know published widely in
machine learning algorithm a game theory
and quantitative finance he's beyond his
scholarship he's worked in the finance
and technology industries he's consulted
for government agencies and companies on
legal and regulatory matters involving
algorithms data and machine learning he
co-authored an introduction to
computational learning theory and beyond
of that I was as I mentioned we had a
great session last night
at seattle town hall with aaron roth his
co-author on the ethical algorithm and
as i mentioned last night to the
audience i have ability like the stick
memory of first meeting michael in at
you AI 1986 in philadelphia he was right
over here at the side of the room and I
looked over and he was making a giving a
presentation I was very impressed with
his crispness and I thought to him
because we had the old-timers the
founders of the UI conference from 1985
I was the first one we were all there
and who is this new person who is
staying all these interesting things and
I followed his work ever since then he
and Aaron Roth wrote this I think I
think fabulous book I had to read it
because I moderated the session at
Seattle Town Hall last night and I was
really happy to have forced myself to
read every page of it and really really
enjoyed it it's a really fabulous
contribution to the discussion on the
role of algorithms and the rising
interest in their influence inadvertent
and even malicious in the in the world
and the fact that the book goes from
some of the topics we all know and study
fairness and bias and
and intelligibility and explanation and
privacy issues that many topics we cover
at Microsoft Research and on the ether
committee efforts microsoft also dives
into science which I thought was a my
favorite chapter on you know sort of the
how the inferences we make in our
scientific endeavors are a great a great
bulk of of these inferences and results
are likely to be non reproducible and
false with that Michael okay thanks Eric
for the kind introduction in for your
terrific madhuri moderating last night
it was a great event and it's great to
be here actually somehow in my now long
career i've never managed to make it to
MSR redmond so this is kind of a bucket
list visit for me i'm happy to be here
rich i spend time in cambridge i've
spent a lot of time in the new york lab
i visited the new england lab but i've
never actually been to the mothership so
yeah yeah yeah yeah I was so yeah so my
close friend and colleague at Penn Aaron
Roth and I decided a couple years ago to
write a general audience book and I'm
gonna do something a little unusual with
this talk because I get the feeling that
on the one hand it's a diverse audience
but on the other hand there are probably
some card-carrying AI ml researchers in
the room and so what I want to do is
spend the first half of my time kind of
giving the description of the book that
we give to rather general audiences at
the risk of boring the more technical
people in the room but I'm kind of
hoping that even if I'm shredding over
territory that you know well
scientifically or at least familiar with
in theme you might find it interesting
just the way that we try to phrase it
for a more general audience and get
something out of it for that reason and
for those of you that haven't seen these
topics I'm hoping it'll just be
interesting out right but then what I
want to do is spend time at the end
doing a more deep
on recent algorithmic work that we and
others have been doing on more refined
notions of fairness in machine learning
and related areas so our book is called
the ethical algorithm and this would the
subtitle the science of socially aware
algorithm design it just came out
officially a couple of weeks ago
although it's been shipping from Amazon
for a little bit longer than that I mean
so what is this book about
so you know quickly on the heels of the
rush of excitement around the Great's
empirical successes of AI and machine
learning in the earlier part of this
decade quickly came like the buzzkill of
reports about all kinds of what we might
call anti-social behavior by algorithms
often but not always algorithms that
really we might more accurately refer to
as models because they are the output of
an algorithm that took data that it
trained a model on and then the thing
that's actually deployed and making the
decisions is let's say a neural network
for example and you know it's an
interesting time to work in the
so-called fate area fairness
accountability transparency and ethics
because literally you know I'm giving
variants of this talk you know all the
time these days and pretty much every
single time I'm able to include a fresh
mainstream media news report on
antisocial behavior by algorithms I'll
mention this week's favorites a little
bit later in the talk
but you know this is this has been kind
of in the public consciousness enough
for long enough now that there are some
good general audience books that precede
us on these topics
you've probably heard or read some of
these like weapons of mass destruction
algorithms of oppression these are
really about kind of bias and unfairness
in algorithmic decision-making and books
like data and Goliath which are you know
kind of examining privacy and security
issues and making the argument that we
have essentially arrived at something
akin to a surveillance state and you
know Aaron and I I think many people in
this room doing technical work in these
areas we like these books but and feel
like they do an excellent job of
identifying real problems and making
them kind of visceral to ordinary
readers and so we admire
these books and consider them
inspirations but we were disappointed in
these books when they came to the parts
about you know what to do about these
problems what the solutions might be and
all these all these books have sections
like that usually a little bit towards
the end and I perhaps unfairly
paraphrase but I think they're they're
kind of about the form like well you
know we need better laws we need better
regulations and policies we need
watchdog groups you know kind of we
really need to keep an eye on this stuff
and Aaron and I agree firmly with all of
that but the part that we we're
disappointed with is the fact that as
researchers in the field know you know
if if there are problems with algorithm
algorithmic misbehavior you could also
contemplate making the algorithms better
in the first place you know fixing the
algorithms in some sense so that they
don't in you know entail violations of
privacy or racial or gender
discrimination and the like and you know
to be fair some of these books I think
were written when that research agenda
was still rather immature and we don't
know as much as we do now but our goal
in writing our book was to kind of tell
the world that there there is a science
you know you can make scientific a lot
of these questions or a lot of these
problems of unfairness privacy
violations interpretability etc and
design alguns that are you know
demonstrably better in the first place
and so our book is kind of a survey
about why you would want to do that how
things go wrong in the first place what
the potential algorithmic solutions are
and also what this what the costs of
those algorithmic solutions will be
because there will be costs to them as
well as as we'll discuss an early in an
early draft that we was sent around for
you know for comments and input from
various people by our publisher we got a
very interesting critique back in which
the the critic basically said you know
your title kind of is is a conundrum or
doesn't make sense you know why would
you talk about ethical algorithms
because you wouldn't talk about ethical
for instance so the point that this
reviewer was making is that look you
know a hammer is a tool it is a human
artifact designed for a specific purpose
and even though of course that tool can
be misused
perhaps in unethical ways I could hit
you on the hand with a hammer nobody you
know nobody would sort of think to
ascribe that moral lapse or ethical
failing to the hammer itself they would
blame me for hitting you on the hand
with it and so this this critics
argument was you know algorithms are the
same way you shouldn't talk about
algorithms being ethical or not and you
shouldn't talk about like the moral
failings of algorithms you should talk
about the moral failings of the
designers of algorithms and we we
thought carefully about this comment and
and we disagree we think that algorithms
even though they are also tools and
artifacts designed for particular
purposes there's a number of things that
give algorithms kind of a different
ethical or moral stature than their
designers okay and you know we go into
more detail on this in the book but the
basic argument that we make is look
especially in the ear of machine
learning it can be hard to assign blame
to the designer of an algorithm due to
the multiple steps involved in the
machine learning pipeline and the sort
of levels of indirection involved so you
know that pipeline usually starts with
data gathered from somewhere and you may
not know exactly what that how that data
was gathered or exactly what every
attribute means and furthermore that
data might be a hybrid of multiple data
sources whose provenance is sort of
uncertainty so already from the
beginning the input to your algorithm
might be of uncertain origins and you
might not know for instance if it's
police data whether the arresting
officers might have been racially biased
in the first place and so the data that
you see from the beginning has that
encoded into it we then usually use this
data to define some sort of objective
function or landscape and primarily that
objective function will be will
primarily be concerned with predictive
accuracy for example and as well say
this is one of the problems
of course we take that data in that
objective function and use some
complicated optimization procedure like
stochastic gradient descent on a
multi-layer neural network and we get
some rather complicated looking model
and the point is is that after all these
steps are done you know not only can it
be hard you know if the algorithm causes
harm to some specific individual not
only can it be difficult to sort of say
that the algorithm designer was
specifically responsible for that
particular misdeed unlike when I hit you
on the hand with a hammer we may not
even know that these harms are being
caused until we decide to look at them
so if I hit you on the hand with a
hammer both of us know what has happened
and it's very clear that a harm has been
caused to you in algorithmic
decision-making often the harms are
subtle diffuse and until somebody
bothers to look and document them we
don't even know that they're happening
okay so the basic premise of our book
and the research field that we are
trying to represent to a broader
audience is that we need to in addition
to legal regulatory policy and other
solutions we need to think about
embedding social values into our
algorithms and so I literally mean
changing the code of our algorithms in
order to a court incorporate social
norms that we care about now one of the
interesting things maybe the most
interesting thing about this exercise is
that you know of course if you're going
to explain something to an algorithm if
you're going to encode a social norm
into an algorithm you have to be
exceedingly precise in your definition
of that that social norm right you need
to be able to write the code that
implements it and so even though we will
be the first to acknowledge that there
are centuries or maybe eons of scholars
and thinkers of all variety who've
thought about you know fairness for way
longer than we have and privacy for way
longer than we have and you know other
topics as well you know legal scholars
philosophers economists etc that have
thought about these issues have never
had to think so precisely about them
that they could be put into a computer
program and some
the very act of forcing yourself to
think that precisely will expose flaws
in your intuitions about topics like
fairness and privacy that you wouldn't
have uncovered if you were thinking in a
looser more macroscopic way okay so I'm
listing here several different social
norms that are ones that there's a lot
of discussion these days about you know
can we encode these so can we define
give satisfying definitions of these
different notions and then encode them
in our algorithms and you know that you
notice that they're in in kind of
increasing greyscale here as we go from
top to bottom and roughly that greyscale
represents in our view how much is known
scientifically about these topics at
this moment so we feel that for instance
the study of data privacy and algorithms
for enforcing data privacy is the most
mature of these topics and and
furthermore isn't the most mature but
has kind of a central definition that we
argue is the right definition which is
differential privacy which I'll talk
about in a minute the study of fairness
is off to a fast start it's much much
more recent but as we'll see it's it's
still more embryonic and we already know
that it's going to be Messier there
won't be a definition you know there
won't be a differential privacy of
fairness in the way that all in the way
that I'll describe we already know that
we are gonna have to maintain multiple
notions of fairness and this is just the
reacts I until Acree ality similarly we
have things like accountability and
interpretability which we talk less
about in the book not because we think
they're less important but there's less
to say scientifically of the type of
science that we're interested in here
and then one might of course already put
morality here and I promise you there's
a final bullet there which is the
singularity but you can't see it because
it's entirely in white okay so what I
want to do just in the in the first part
of this talk is spend a little bit of
time talking about privacy and fairness
which together with the introduction
takes up about the first half of the
book and again these are the areas where
I think we're on the firmest ground and
give you a sample of what's known there
and and why this process of thinking
hard about
munitions can be quite revealing even in
and of itself then I'll take one slide
to kind of tell you about the second
half of the book which takes an
interesting left turn but a related left
turn and then what I want to do in the
last part of the talk maybe last third
maybe a little bit more if I'm lucky is
just tell you more about some scientific
some actual research going on in this
area that we and others have been
involved in in trying to move fairness
definitions from these very aggregate
coarse group definitions to ones that
provide stronger guarantees to
individuals in a population rather than
just groups okay so that's the game plan
and so let me just start off with
privacy okay by the way you know I won't
call it out specifically as I go through
this talk but the influence of MSR is
all over in this talk and all over in
the book you know so differential
privacy was founded by Cynthia Doric and
her co-author z-- when she was at
Microsoft a lot of the fairness research
that we implicitly discuss in the book
and that influences our own research is
done by MSR people which has a fantastic
faith group but but so let me start off
by you know talking about you know why
thinking hard about definitions is a
valuable thing even before you getting
or get around to putting it into
algorithms so this quote at the top of
the slide here is actually due to
cynthia dork anonymized data isn't and
the way to parse that is that you know
either
you haven't anonymized the data and so
it's not anonymized data or you've
anonymized it so much that it's not
really data anymore okay and so it's not
useful for anything and so prior to
differential privacy or you know maybe
even to this day
um the prevailing formal definitions of
privacy including all those in my view
unfortunately that are in force in
industry and and practice today are all
based on notions of anonymization or you
know things like removing personally
identifiable
information PII and so the basic idea is
you try to get some sense of privacy or
some assurances of privacy by taking a
data set and redacting certain columns
entirely or corseting others in the hope
that sort of you know by doing this you
can't re identify any particular people
in the data set okay so in this toy
example at the top there is a database
of medical records from a hospital maybe
it's the hospital of the University of
Pennsylvania and in the efforts to
anonymize you know it's been decided
that names should be redacted entirely
ages rather than being given precisely
should be grouped by decades genders
left alone zip code last two digits are
redacted etc etc so some columns we've
removed entirely others we've coarsened
okay and one notion that's popular in
kind of the scientific literature on
anonymity would say something like okay
you should you know you should do these
two operations redaction and coarsening
until your database has the property
that prefer any particular individual or
line in that course and dataset there
are many many records that match it so
whereas before this redaction coarsening
maybe you know your medical record was
unique in the sense that you know nobody
else's attributes matched exactly yours
the goal here is to make lots of people
match and so then there's you know
allegedly confusion about who's who okay
so for example at the top you know this
is a two anonymous data set in the sense
that for any particular entry in this
table there's at least one other
matching entry and so let's suppose for
the sake of argument that you have a
neighbor and so because she's your
neighbor you know stuff about her that
you couldn't like to get out of this
redacted database you know that her name
is Rebecca and you know that she's a 57
year old woman okay
so from this other source of data that
you know about your neighbor you can go
look at this database and say like okay
there's two possible records that match
what I know about Rebecca and
the ones highlighted in red and so now
you have some uncertainty right the idea
is like now you don't sure which one
belongs to Rebecca I note that already
you know that she's either HIV or has
colitis and she might consider your
knowing the or of those a violation of
her privacy already and you might try to
wish this away by saying okay I know in
a real medical database there'd be ten
thousand records and I might do enough
of this that a hundred records match
meant Rebecca and so now I'm really
confused about what her diagnosis is the
real problem of course is you know
triangulation right or or you know
linkage analysis is sometimes called so
in this second database which is maybe
the database of Jefferson Hospital in
Philadelphia you might also know that
Rebecca had been a patient there maybe
you gave her a ride there one morning
and so in this database you know this
has been sufficiently anonymized that
three records match Rebecca and now of
course from the join of these two
databases you uniquely know from the top
and the bottom that she's HIV okay and
you know you can try to wish this away
in various senses but maybe the most
damning thing that I could say about
this entire category of definition is a
statement in plain English which is the
problem with definitions like this is
that they pretend like the data set in
front of us is the only data set that
exists in the world or that will ever
exist in the world in perpetuity and
they don't anticipate other information
I might know like about my neighbor
Rebecca because she's my neighbor or
other publicly available information
that all of us have offered about
ourselves thinking that it's innocuous
like our activity on Facebook or our
social media posts okay and so we argue
in the book that these types of
definitions are fundamentally flawed and
one of the one of the reasons that
they're fundamentally flawed is that
they're kind of ad hoc they don't they
don't start off by saying this is what
privacy should mean and now can we
design algorithms that meet that
definition of privacy they sort of say
like oh look you know if you do this
then it sure seems like there's some
guarantee of anonymity here and I would
I would offer a very crude metaphor
which is from Krypton
rafi so those of you that know the
history of cryptography in my view the
history of cryptography up until like
the development of public key
cryptography in the 70s more or less had
the form like oh well if we scramble up
the letters this way it sure looks
random and it looks random until it
doesn't look so random to somebody until
somebody cracks the code and then it's
all over and the advent of public key
cryptography in the 70s basically put
the study of encryption and security
more generally on kind of firm
algorithmic footing right it basically
gave a definition that said this is the
criterion that should be met and then
the question is can you design
algorithms that meet that so continuing
with this metaphor we think that the you
know if if things like anonymization
were are like you know pre public key
cryptography data privacy we think that
sort of the corresponding landmark in
privacy to public key cryptography is
differential privacy but before I talk
about differential privacy let me let me
say like okay so I've pointed out one
flawed type of definition for privacy
let's step back for a second and say
well what would be what would be the
strongest definition of privacy that we
could possibly ask for okay and again
you can make this mathematical if you
want to and people have but in plain
English one perhaps strongest definition
of privacy I could give is I could say
look it should be the case that any
analysis that involves your private data
whether it's you know the release of a
data set that's in a course and in some
way or the result of a computation that
involved your data in that computation
or the release of statistics about a
database in which your data was present
whatever it is no harm should come to
you as a result of that statistic
analysis or computation period full stop
okay so certainly that is a very strong
definition of privacy like nothing bad
can ever happen to you from an analysis
that involved your data okay let me
argue that this is asking too much this
is asking too much because if we insist
on the
we basically won't be able to do
anything with data including many things
that we'd very much like to be able to
do so suppose it is 1950 and I picked
that year very particularly and suppose
you're a smoker and if it's 1950 you're
almost certainly a smoker because in
1950 pretty much everybody as a smoker
there are no known there's no health
stigma associated with it there's no
social stigma associated with it it's
actually seen as fashionable and
glamorous okay and suppose you were
asked to participate in a medical study
that that asked for your medical record
and your smoking habits which was
actually conducted in a famous study in
England in the 1950s or after the period
I'm proposing that you were a smoker and
you go ahead and you say sure go ahead
and use my medical record and then as it
did this record this this medical study
establishes a firm link between smoking
and lung cancer okay so the fact you
were smoker was public knowledge you
didn't hide it everybody that knows you
knew that you were a smoker now your
medical record was used in the study and
now the world knows that smoking and
lung cancer are linked and now
everybody's posterior belief about your
having cancer goes up as a result of
this study and in particular your
insurer might raise your premiums
because of this Bayesian update so to
speak okay so we could really say that
actual harm came to you your data was
used in this analysis this analysis
established this link between smoking
and lung cancer so harm has come to you
as a result of this study so therefore
under the definition of privacy that I
proposed you wouldn't be able to do this
study okay so clearly this is asking too
much in the sense that we won't be able
to do scientific research that's data
driven if we insist on this notion of
privacy and this brings us to the
definition of differential privacy which
is a similar kind of definition but
weakened in an important way that sort
of makes it practical while still
providing very strong guarantees and so
the observation here is that in this
story about the
smoking and lung cancer you know even
though your medical record was used in
that study it's not like your medical
record was the key day piece of data
that established the correlation between
smoking and lung cancer the correlation
between smoking and lung cancer is what
we might call a fact about the world
that can be discovered from any
sufficiently large data set it wasn't
that your data sets your data's
inclusion was crucial it was just that
there is enough data okay so so the
definition of differential privacy
sounds similar but is weakened in an
important way it basically says that no
harm should come to you as a result of
an analysis involving your data that
wasn't going to happen to you already
if you hadn't included your data okay so
you do a thought experiment in which you
imagine an algorithm that's let's say
getting many people's medical records as
input and you you basically say privacy
is preserved if for any particular
individual in the input database if we
compare the result of the computation
including all of the data and the result
of the computation in which we have n
minus 1 records would just your record
removed if that if the output is almost
exactly the same then we have
differential privacy okay and if one
looks at the definition of differential
privacy you'll see that interestingly it
requires randomization because the
notion of the output being nearly the
same as a distributional notion so on
any given input the algorithm induces a
distribution over possible outputs okay
and what can't change much when we
include or don't include your data is
that distribution in a technical sense
that's quite standard okay and to
demystify this a little bit the way
differential privacy works the way you
achieve differential privacy when you
can achieve it is by adding
randomization to computations so if for
example I want to publish in a
differentially private way the average
salary of all Microsoft employees what I
do is I do the tradition
non-private computation which I just
take everybody's salaries I averaged
them together and I output two numerical
precision what the average salary is I
don't do that
I do the precise computation and then I
add let's say Gaussian noise with zero
mean to that number that I get okay
and it turns out by adding the right
amount of noise you get two desirable
properties nobody you you you obey
differential privacy for each individual
salary in the input data set but yet the
output will still be quite useful so to
a first a first approximation it's fair
to say in this specific example if there
are n employees of Microsoft and I add
sort of order noise whose variance is on
the order of one over square root of n I
will achieve this definition
okay now differential privacy I think
was first defined in about 2005 and it's
you know it's theory underwent a great
deal of development in the ten years
subsequently when I first saw the
definition of differential privacy I'm a
relatively recent
you know researcher in the topic when my
first when I first saw it I said like
well okay that's a great definition of
privacy that's you know kind of the
strongest definition you could provide
while still hoping to do useful things
with data but I was worried that it's
too strong did like you know interest
the computations that we want to do and
machine learning for instance wouldn't
be able to be made differentially
private subsequent work has like you
know happily shown me to have been wrong
so for example pretty much every method
tool or computation you know in
statistics and machine learning whether
it's classical hypothesis testing
methods or back propagation for neural
networks
none of them are differentially private
all of them have modifications that are
differentially private and still give
answers that are quite close to the non
private deterministic computations so we
know how to do machine learning in a
differentially private way and
differential privacy has started to
gradually creep into practice and
products so the so for instance Apple
was one of the first companies to field
differential
privacy in the iOS reporting of app
usage statistics to the mothership in
Cupertino the big moonshot test for
differential privacy is coming next year
when the US census has decided that
every single report or statistics it
releases based on census data will be
done under the constraint of
differential privacy and we talked about
this a little bit in the book but
there's you know even though the theory
is well in hand we know how to do all
this stuff in principle there's a lot of
engineering considerations that have to
be made including about the trade-off
between how much noise you add which you
know of course adding more noise gives
you more privacy there's a knob here and
but you'll have less accurate answers
there collecting detailed data and
storing it how they look but the but how
they share it will be done under the
constraint of difference and they have
to buy by law collect that you know they
have this this is why they can't
randomly sample they actually need to
literally canvass every single residence
in the United States or try to yeah so
my question is related to your comment
on the pragmatics of differential
privacy and experience so the issue is
that when you think about a very vanilla
database system or a data system which
serves a vast a question like a
relational database system it gives
answers it seems to me that what you are
saying is that the notion of
differential privacy has to be very
tightly coupled with the task you're
trying to do so I'm if that's the case
it creates the problem for the system
developers because yes I want to play my
relational database system can support
differential privacy what is this
supposed to really mean because that's
where is after I get a result required
you become way if people do it is they
do a selection and then you know at some
point there's a trade-off that you
referred to within usability yeah so if
I understand your question correctly I
disagree with your characterization so
one subset of techniques in differential
privacy is to take a database and to
release a synthetic version of that data
set database so the odd you know
so it's not like differential privacy's
only good if I have a database and I
want to run backpropagation on it if I
have a database and I and the object I
want to share with people is a database
so that they can do sequel queries the
database has actual records in it that
you can look at you know it's rows and
columns it's a spreadsheet one technique
in differential privacy is to start with
an original database and to produce a
version of it okay there will be a
database and will basically preserve the
statistics of the original database so
there'll be some set of queries that you
might have wanted to run on that
original database and what will and what
will promise what differential privacy
will promise you can't you can't do this
by the way in all cases but when you can
do this the synthetic database will
preserve up to some error all of the
statistics in some class of statistics
on the that of the original database
okay you're you're going down a great
line here if you can pre specify that
class you can get away with adding less
noise because you were able to commit to
that before if if it's adaptive it's
more complicated and by the way this
ties in with the chapter that Eric was
mentioning about the reproducibility
crisis and the sciences where you
essentially are doing adaptive data
analysis you form a hypothesis you
gather some data your hypothesis was
wrong but you saw something else that's
interesting so then you formulate a new
hub and and the Quinns sort of a lot of
the questions that you're asking or but
like when can you do that when is that
okay when can you do that without like
you know creating entire fields of false
science right like like food science for
example okay okay so let me so that's a
little bit about privacy and about why
thinking hard about definitions can sort
of expose flaws and your thinking and
lead you to a better definition I want
to sort of tell you you know where we
are in that agenda with fairness yeah
just a general
all right is there any discussion about
defining privacy in the terms of harm so
actually if you dig into the definition
of so differential privacy has there's
multiple ways you can phrase the
definition that are equivalent but let
me let me tell you the original
formulation which is exactly of the type
that you're you're described so so the
definition of epsilon differential
privacy basically says the following you
have some private data you're
contemplating on whether to contribute
it to some computation that will include
lots of other people's data as well take
whatever event it is whatever outcome
now we're in the future it is that
you're worried about that you think
constitutes harm so this might be you
know the world learning about your
medical condition this might be your
insurance premiums being raised it might
mean getting robo calls on your cell
phone whatever harm it is you're worried
about you get to pick it okay
the promise of differential privacy is
that with respect to sort of the output
distribution of a differentially private
algorithm that the you know consider the
probability that this harm was going to
come to you if you didn't allow your
data to be used and the probability that
this harm will come to you if you allow
your data to be used
those two probabilities whatever you're
worried about are within 1 plus or minus
Epsilon at each other the seiner this is
a universal quantifier anything that
you're worried about including things
that you can't even articulate or think
about yourself are protected by this
definition every single one of them okay
let me go on and talk about fairness so
we already know that the study of
fairness is unfortunately going to be
Messier more complicated than privacy
one things that was interesting about
writing this book is I'm like okay
privacy is a social norm fairness is a
social norm discussions around fairness
are much more divisive in
society than discussions about privacy
at a high level you know people have
different attitudes about privacy for
themselves but in general people are
like you know privacy is a good thing
and we should all have it okay with
fairness you need to talk about fair to
whom for example and you know you
immediately go down paths that are you
know very divisive and evoke strong
emotions from people but so it's not
just kind of messy in that social way
it's also we know it's gonna be messy
technically so we don't agree on the
definitions in fact as a result of some
very public controversies over fairness
and criminal sentencing software for
example researchers you know a couple of
different groups independently noted
kind of what I might call like arrows
impossibility theorem for fairness so
these are papers that say okay look here
are three here are three different
axiomatic properties that you'd like any
definition of fairness to me right and
you know you look at these three
properties and you say yes yes these are
very weak properties any definition of
fairness should certainly meet these
three properties and I'd like any
definition of fairness to actually be
stronger than this okay and then of
course the punchline of the paper is
well guess what here is a proof that you
cannot achieve those three properties
simultaneously period okay so this means
that not only will as with privacy there
be trade-offs between you know the
social norm
privacy or unfairness and and predictive
accuracy there will actually be
trade-offs there may be trade-offs
between different notions of privacy so
it really might mean that if I want to
build a predictive model that reduces
racial discrimination I literally have
to do that at the cost of increased
gender discrimination like this maybe
the reality and there's just no
squirreling around it and you know
stakeholders and society will have to
make hard decisions about these kinds of
things right people like us can
articulate these trade-offs but you know
real you know real stakeholders have to
to make their choices about them but so
I live I get a little bit ahead of
myself let me just give a very brief
tutorial for those who might have not
seen these examples about why machine
learning even in its standard principled
form might result in discrimination of
various kinds and here's just as I
promised you know the two latest media
articles about apparent unfairness in
statistical modeling one from a paper
from science from a couple of weeks ago
that established that a widely used
health assessment tool used in many many
large US hospitals had systemic racial
bias in it and then the other one that
you might have heard about I don't think
this one has been scientifically
established even though New York has
does Orion launched an investigation you
might have seen these media stories
about the fact that Apple's new credit
card to several couples who tweeted
about it offered to the husband a credit
limit that was ten times that offered to
the wife even though they filed joint
taxes and the wife had a higher credit
rating okay so doesn't look good for
Apple okay but let me let me go back to
basics here for a second and give you
another kind of toy example along the
lines of my medical databases you know
suppose Aaron and I are asked to help
the Penn admissions office build a
predictive model for success in college
based only on let's say high school GPA
and SAT score so here each plus or minus
here has an X value representing the GPA
of some of some student and the Y value
has their SAT score and let's suppose
that these are students that were
previously admitted to Penn this is
historical data so we know for each one
of these individuals whether they
succeeded in college or not and for
success in college pick any objectively
you know quantifiable notion of success
that we like maybe it's they graduated
within five years with at least a 3.0
GPA they donated twenty million dollars
back to Penn within thirty years of
graduating you pick your favorite okay
as long as we can measure it okay and so
there's a couple of things I want you to
notice about this cloud of points first
of all if you looked carefully at it
you'd seen that this population
of app of past students slightly less
than half of them succeeded there's a
few more minuses than pluses here okay
in general as you might expect the
pluses are sort of towards the
upper-right higher SAT scores in GPA and
if I was asked to build a predictive
model from this data I'm you know a
simple threshold rule seems to do a
pretty good job if I sort of predict
success for everybody above that blue
line and and not in success for
everybody below I make some mistakes
right there's some minuses above the
line and some pluses below the line but
it does a pretty good job okay okay now
can suppose though there's also a second
population sub population in our
historical data the red population and I
want you to notice a few things about
the red population first of all they are
a minority in the dictionary sense of
that word right there are many fewer of
them than the orange population notice
that they're equally or even slightly
better prepared for collegiate success
half of them are plus half of them are -
but notice also compared to the orange
cloud that the SAT scores though all
these red points just seem like they're
shifted down compared to the orange
points in particular their SAT scores
are lower okay and you know one
explanation for this might be that the
orange demographic is wealthier and pays
for SAT preparation courses and multiple
retakes of the exam and reports only the
highest and the minority red population
doesn't have the financial resources for
that so they just take the exam cold
once and that's it okay now notice also
that you know if I build a predictive
model for the red minority population
there's now a perfect classifier for
separating + from - but if I combine the
two populations and I just say look the
overall goal is to maximize predictive
accuracy minimize the number of false
positives and false false negatives then
basically I'm still going to pick the
model that's determined by the orange
majority because you can see if I try to
shift that line down to include the red
pluses
I will pick up so many more false admits
from the oranges that it won't be worth
it okay so this is one of several ways
that just the the you know usually sound
principles of machine learning can
result in a model that has systemic
racial discrimination now you might
notice like well look suppose and
suppose we just noticed this thing about
SAT scores it's not that the red
population is less successful in college
they just for whatever reason have lower
SAT scores I might propose a hybrid
model in which I say like look if
they're an orange applicant use the
upper line and if they're a red
applicant use the lower line okay and
not only would have I in is this a more
fair model right now the false rejection
rates between the two populations are
much closer than they were before now
I'm actually more accurate as well so
this is what I would call like a Pareto
improvement if my two criteria are
fairness and accuracy I've actually made
both of them better unfortunately many
laws and regulations in the United
States in for instance areas like
lending explicitly forbid this type of
model because this is a race-based model
right I am looking at the race of the
applicant orange or red first and then
you know it's like it's like a decision
tree if they're Orange do this if
they're if they're red do that and so
this is kind of points out how
wrongheaded those rules and definitions
are this idea that you know by excluding
race as a variable from your model that
you're going to protect a minority group
this simple example shows you that not
only might you not be helping that
minority group or protecting them you
might be actively enforcing damage on
them by refusing to allow the model to
look at this variable okay okay now
notice though that if I wanted to fix
this problem algorithmically there's
kind of a straightforward path to doing
so so in particular right for any
particular you know line like this one I
can write down two numbers I can
down it's overall error rate on the data
on the entire data set the two
populations combined but another number
I could write down is there's the sort
of unfairness measure right so in this
case I might say that that what
constitutes harm is false rejection
rejecting somebody that would have
succeeded in college by our definition
and this particular model here right has
a false rejection rate on the orange
population that's quite small it's
basically the fraction of pluses below
that blue orange pluses below that blue
line but it's false rejection rate on
the red population is a hundred percent
every one of the red pluses is rejected
by this model okay
but so now I could change my objective I
can basically say instead of just like
minimize the overall error I could solve
a constrained minimization problem
minimize the error subject to the
constraint that the false rejection rate
between the two populations is zero or I
could turn that knob and say the false
positive rejection disparity has to be
at most one percent or five percent or
ten percent if I crank that knob all the
way up to a hundred percent it's like
I'm not asking for any fairness at all
okay so this gives me a knob that lets
me tune the trade-off between accuracy
and and fairness or err and unfairness
and when you do that you know you trace
out what we would call like the
efficient or Pareto frontier right you
get you get a class of models
corresponding to the different trade
offs you can make between these two on
quantities so on three real different
data sets I won't go into the detail you
know each red dot corresponds to like a
different model the x-axis is the error
of that model
okay so lower is better the y-axis is
the false positive false rejection
disparity or the unfairness of that
model so again lower is better we'd like
to be at zero zero that's not happening
on any of these curves we can choose to
go for the lowest possible error
ignoring fairness and we'll get bad
unfairness we can choose to go for
zero disparity or unfairness and get the
worst error or we can get anything in
between now there are lots of models
that are not on this line right there
above this line and to the right you
don't ever want to consider those models
if these are your two criteria because
they're dominated right you could always
move to a model on the efficient
frontier and improve in one or possibly
both of these measures but you know one
of the points we make in the book is
that whatever social norm you decide to
encode in your algorithm whether it's
privacy or fairness it's gonna come at a
cost at a minimum it's gonna come at a
cost to predictive accuracy and these
curves are exactly quantifying what that
trade-off looks like and then it's again
up to stakeholders right if if this is
sort of you know you know false false
rejection disparity in admissions
decisions and this is accuracy of our
predictions admissions offices need to
get used to looking at a plot like this
and committing to a point on it and
justifying that point yeah question your
definition of fairness and the inclusion
of race and criteria why just not
conditioning on something like household
income which predicts race but also
identifies you know majority factors
where they can't retake the test either
right
if you're from a low-income group but a
majority group you also can't retake the
test and presumably the same argument
you gave applies to that group as well
that they would be skewed there
essentially because it's not a good
measure overall probably to perform over
multiple tests I'm not quite sure I
followed what the Western is you
proposed the argument that race should
be included explicitly to to fix some of
these issues but the underlying causal
argument you gave was household income
and access to resources I'm not
proposing that including race fixes
anything I'm proposing that insisting on
excluding it might cause harm they're
not the same thing
right so you know another way of putting
it as we put it in the book is that we
think that good fairness definitions and
unfortunately or fortunately there are
multiple competing good definitions of
fairness I mentioned but they should
basically constrain the output of your
predictions they shouldn't constrain the
inputs right you're fooling yourself if
you think
oh by excluding race as a variable that
on somehow not racially biased or that
there aren't other proxies for race like
zip code in my data set so we're saying
like if your if your way of thinking is
like oh I want to protect these
different groups and so I'm gonna
exclude what kind of we just think that
that's false thinking and that you're
fooling yourself and can cause active
damage we don't say that like not doing
those things guarantees like fairness we
but we think that the right definitions
of fairness basically say you know your
model should not exhibit this empirical
behavior that's a violation of fairness
and then it's up to an algorithm
designer to figure out whether you can
achieve that criterion or not and at
what cost it should be included as part
of the metric but not as part of the
optimization I I'm not I I don't have I
don't have a prescription or
recommendation for what inputs you use
in building a model I think fairness
should be something that you define on
the behavior of the model and and you
know if you can do you can achieve that
definition excluding or excluding
certain variables then fine but we don't
think the definition of fairness should
be like oh you know it is a model is
racially fair as long as it doesn't
mention race as a variable that that's
you know this is I think kind of roughly
akin to anonymization definitions and
privacy yeah coming in I think that
whether it's a proxy or not the goal
here is you still want to have enough
inputs that you can discriminate
appropriately and I the word
discriminate are used intentionally here
because the whole point of any
classifiers is to discriminate and put
things in a right yeah right group I
understand what you're saying it's a
confusing use of the word in the context
of like discrimination of the social
variety but yeah and so I I mean it's
the comment is if you don't use raise
but you still want to find the
appropriate signal coming in wherever
it's from or the data
so that you can organize and get the
right result coming in there and I think
that's yeah so in general like if we
that's not a Laredo sort of
computational and data resources set
aside if I didn't care about fairness
you know I want to add as many features
to my model as possible just in case
they might have some marginal predictive
value especially if I'm building
something complicated like a deep neural
network but but of course when you do
that you know you also introduce more
opportunities for things to go wrong of
the variety that I described on the last
slide and this is why we and others
argue that you need like a crisp
definition about fairness that sort of
is agnostic to what inputs the algorithm
used but constrains its actual behavior
yeah right so ago you rejected the use
of race as a choice of model right I use
different models what you've done race
you reject as being not legal I mean I
didn't reject it as maybe not legal the
law reject constraints equally speaking
what's the difference your students in
what in in the constructs you're hearing
things you're using the false positive
you myrrh popular race as well as the
constraints that's right and so some of
what I'm suggesting here depending on
the application area might violate
current law so so like our goal in the
stud scientific study of fairness is not
to adhere to current laws that we think
make no sense we think eventually those
laws will need to be rewritten just go
back if your argue we could use we
should use race of the factor make
decision why don't we just use race it
has to be clear like in this toy example
allowing this two-part model will not
necessarily solve all racial
discrimination I can give you a
different data set in which even when I
let you have a two-part model that uses
race you still will have discrimination
against one population or the other and
you need to explicitly it
to enforce a fairness constraint in your
optimization okay so just because you
know this example is constructed to sort
of show you one thing that can break you
know the thing that fixes that in this
particular example is not a general
solution for that problem
unbelievable race because you know you
are going to get to a situation I can
define a sub population at home like a
predicate with a predicate and say hey I
want to be sort of be fair to them and
if I start asking this you know random
collection of predicates that define the
sub population if I get to it this is
exactly sort of some of the research
that I would talk about but Eric advised
me on how much time I actually okay so
we'll come to exactly this question
shortly okay so before I get to sort of
the researchy
part of the talk let me just quickly
tell you what happens in the rest of the
book and about midway through the book
we take you know as I said one of a wide
left term but we think an interesting
and relevant wide left turn and let me
kind of tell you what the the basis of
that left turn is in all the examples
I've given so far about violations of
privacy or fairness and the like and in
many other of the social norms that I
had listed on that kind of grey scale
list at the beginning like you know
interpretability accountability and the
like it really seems fair to a first
approximation to think about individual
citizens or consumers as the victims of
algorithms so in particular you know
maybe you get rejected for a loan by an
algorithm you don't even know that it
was an algorithm that rejected you you
know you haven't you have no idea that
it wasn't a human loan officer that
looked carefully and you know thought
about your application you know you
might not even know this and similarly
you might not know if your data was used
to build such a model that made
decisions about other people
we might be completely unaware of it and
as I said on the ethical hammer slide
right we might not be aware that certain
types of harms are being caused because
nobody's sort of thought to look for
them yet okay and there's a lot of
different ones that you can imagine in
other settings you know there's an
algorithm at play but it's mediating the
Preferences of a large group of users
who might have strategic or
self-interested considerations and it's
not you know I might even put it at its
meet the album's meeting the preferences
of a large population that might be
competing and it's not so even though
the algorithm or the collective of the
algorithm and its users might exhibit
undesirable social behavior it's not so
easy to entirely blame the algorithm
okay and this is where we kind of get
into the realm of game theory and and
relate it to topics so let me give maybe
what is the cleanest combination of
something that can be precisely
formulated mathematically and that
people have everyday familiarity with
which is you know commuting or driving
on the roadways and the use of
navigation apps like Waze and Google
Maps okay so on the one hand what could
be better than ways in Google Maps
compared to when I grew up when you know
if you wanted you know your goal is
still the same it's not to minimize the
length of the of your you know that the
the miles that you drive its to get from
point A to B the fastest and so traffic
comes into consideration okay and you
know back in the 60s the goal that goal
was still the same I'd like to somehow
figure out the fastest way of getting
from my point A to my point B but the
means I had were like you know fold up
maps in the glove compartment which
would literally just tell you the
roadway is available and maybe like half
hourly traffic reports on just the major
roadways that might be stale by the time
that you know you're on that roadway
okay so what could be better than these
apps right in response to what basically
everybody else is doing right now
all of the other you know all of the
real-time traffic from everybody's GPS
devices these you know algorithms or
apps compute my you know fastest route
from my point A to point B
so in like game theory language I might
even say that they're basically helping
me compute my best response to what
every other driver is doing right now
okay so you can actually think about
commuting or driving it's a game right
it's an incredibly complicated game you
can't write it down like prisoner's
dilemma but it is a game right every
driver on the road is a player every
player has a payoff function or a cost
function which is the time it takes them
to drive from point A to point B these
apps are basically computing your best
response they're computing your optimal
route giving what everyone else is doing
and as such they are literally
essentially encouraging us all to play
the competitive or Nash equilibrium of
this very very complicated game now you
might say like well so what you know how
can that be a bad thing if you've ever
had any game theory you know that just
because something is in equilibrium
doesn't mean that everyone or even
anyone is happy with that outcome and
there are clean mathematical examples
and some real-world evidence that show
that you know at Nash equilibrium we
might collectively be driving let's say
as much of as much as you know a third
more 33% more then we might under some
other solution okay or you know which
which in economics would be called the
maximum social welfare solutions so you
so you can still imagine algorithmic
solutions here you could imagine a
variant of ways that collects the same
information from all it takes real time
GPS information it has a map of traffic
right now but instead of handing out to
everybody their shortest driving time it
does some more sophisticated computation
that tries to minimize our collective
driving time okay so we talked about
this we talked about this not just in
driving but in things like you know
content curation ala Facebook's and news
feed algorithm and many other settings
as well and we kind of go back and forth
between talking about algorithms that
could help these situations in which
you know the system collectively is
exhibiting suboptimal you know behavior
from a social standpoint but the
interesting thing is that you know
unlike fairness and privacy you have to
worry about the incentives so if I
proposed some alternative to Google Maps
and ways that if if we all adopted it
would lower our collective driving time
I need to worry that individual people
might say like well suckers that's great
that you're all doing that but I'm gonna
like open my way you know I'm gonna open
Google Maps and I'm essentially gonna
defect as in prisoner's dilemma and then
you know this would cause us all to
possibly slide back towards the
competitive equilibrium and so we we
talk in this kind of gaming chapter
about the algorithmic issues involved in
making the algorithms better behave
socially but also kind of what the
challenges are from an incentive or
adoption standpoint and then this this
other chapter that Erica mentioned we
kind of you know follow the game theory
chapter the algorithmic game theory
chapter with a discussion of how these
topics play out in data driven
scientific research and how there is
really in some sense a formal game going
on there as well that's basically
established by sort of the incentives of
publishing and of publishers as well and
at a high level this is getting back to
the question you are making you know if
you know you take a field like a machine
learning where we all share these
benchmark datasets and researchers want
to publish in prestigious venues and
we're all kind of munging around on the
same data and looking at each other's
papers so you're influencing and it
making me adapt my hypotheses and the
journals have the property that you
can't publish negative results right if
I you know if I go to the CFR data set
and I try some fancy new algorithm and I
say oh you know I tried this new method
and it is not competitive with the state
of the art I promise you that paper will
not get published at ICML Learner ups
and so you have this like you know you
have this in this machine that is
essentially giving biased reports or
many an uncountable number of
experiments are collectively being run
there's a publication process that only
about the positive ones right so in the
same way that you know you always see
this clickbait you know eat this
particular type of berry and it'll
improve your health and then six months
later you know that's not reproduced or
it's falsified we discuss with some
seriousness the possibility that the
machine learning community is driving
itself in this direction hopefully not
that far yet but we also talked about
algorithmic solutions that interestingly
include approaches involving
differential privacy like by by kind of
adding noise to datasets or by changing
sort of the information that we like you
know provides two competitors in these
large ML competitions we might actually
sort of be able to balance between
having a lot of experiments and research
being done without having these problems
of false discovery and then we do have a
last chapter on the things that we think
are important but on which there's less
kind of firm scientific things to say or
even not even kind of agreed-upon
definitions yet and these include
interpretability accountability and yes
we do even talk a little bit about the
singularity at the end okay so let me
take just for the aficionados in the
audience let me talk just a little bit
about kind of more current research at a
technical level and and one of the
things that our group and others have
been thinking about quite hard lately is
definitions of fairness that provides
stronger guarantees to the individual so
if you think about the types of fairness
definitions i've alluded to so far they
are all group fairness definitions so as
a user of these definitions here's what
you have to specify you first asked to
specify what group or groups it is
you're worried about being harmed if
they you therefore wants to protect okay
so you might be worried about let's say
racial discrimination or gender
discrimination and then you need to say
well what constitutes a harm right and
so you might decide if it's college
admissions I'm worried about racial
discrimination and false rejection is
the harm right sort of somebody that
would have succeeded that I rejected and
I might not think of a false-positive as
a harm that's somebody who wasn't gonna
succeed but got in you know they got
lucky but but the other type of error
I'm gonna consider a harm okay and then
what you basically do is you say like
okay this is the group I want to protect
this is what constitutes a harm and what
I want to do is sort of equalize the
rate of harm across you know the group
I'm trying to project protect in the
majority okay and the the the pros of
these definitions include the fact that
they're relatively easy to implement
right I can kind of adapt my objective
function in the way that I describe and
say like don't just minimize the error
full-stop minimize the error subject to
this false rejection disparity limits so
and they have fairly strong so they have
fairly strong theory and practical
implementations they provide no promises
to individuals so in particular you know
if in the toy example I gave you or a
member of the red minority that was
falsely rejected from college your
consolation for the fact is the
knowledge that I was falsely I'm going
to falsely reject qualified members of
the orange population at an equal rate
so it's like I'm you know I've committed
an injustice to you but you know you
should feel better that I'm also you
know committing that injustice to people
different than you at the other extreme
there is a literature on individual
notions of fairness okay and these
usually have kind of a metric based
quality where you say similar
individuals should be treated similarly
so you know if I have two applicants
that look very similar by some metric of
similarity then they should either both
be admitted or both be rejected but one
shouldn't be admitted or and in general
you know these provide stronger
guarantees at the individual level but
as you pointed out right if I go to the
logical extreme of this right and then I
could sort of say like well every
particular person is a group under
themselves and I want to like equalize
the false rejection rate across all
groups so this is sort of an
a intractable definition because it
doesn't allow me to make any kind of
mistakes at all right as soon as if i
falsely reject one person I've got to
falsely reject everybody okay so so in
general the only you know technical for
the machine learning people in the
audience you kind of to use these
definitions you generally need you know
what we call realizability you need it
to be the case that the ground truth
that you're trying to predict can
actually be represented in your model
class more or less perfectly which is
essentially like a non-starter in the
practice of machine learning okay so
we've been spending a lot of time in the
past several years trying to play around
with definitions that somehow you know
don't go all the way to the rabbit hole
of trying to provide like literally
specific individual fairness guarantees
but are much more refined than these
course group definitions and there's
sort of a lot of technical stuff on this
slide but let me let me let me skip
ahead a little bit and give an example
of the type of the definition that we
have in mind here so let's let's suppose
that let's say in college admissions are
lending we want to make sure that like
the false rejection rates aren't just
approximately equal across racial groups
but also across gender groups and also
perhaps across income levels and age
groups and disability status and the
like okay so I might say like you know
I'm gonna add a lot of constraints no
I'm gonna say minimize the error subject
to the constraint that you know across
gender the rejection the false rejection
rate is the same across ages it's the
same cut it out okay so we know how to
write that optimization problem down
it's not that different from these group
definitions it's just that now there's
you know a handful of groups instead of
one more attributes even if you do this
you still might end up with a model that
badly discriminates against disabled
Hispanic women over age 55 making less
than seventy five thousand dollars a
year because I asked for fairness
marginally in each one of those
attributes and I didn't
mention anything about combinations and
I probably don't need to say it to this
audience but one of the things we say
early and often in the book is that
especially what machine learning on
complex models is involved you should
never expect machine learning to give
you something for free that you didn't
explicitly ask for and you should never
expect to avoid a behavior you don't
want that you didn't tell it explicitly
to avoid okay you just should assume
those things are going to happen if you
didn't say them okay
so this leads us to questions like well
suppose I have a bunch a collection of
attributes and I'd like to not just
promise fairness marginally but on
combinations of them or functions of the
meze have been more generally okay so so
this is sort of interpolating between
group fairness and individual therapist
I'm not going to go all the way down to
combinations of attributes that are so
refined that they they act as a
fingerprint for each one of us
individually but I want to go closer to
that than these group definitions and
you can write this down as a constrained
optimization problem right it's not a
problem to to formulate it it really is
minimize the error subject to the
constraint that for sort of all
combinations of these attributes you
will have this approximate parity
constraint with respect to whatever your
notion of harm is okay where things get
interesting is the algorithmic problem
now because in the example I gave for
instance if there are D of these
attributes that I want to protect there
will be sort of exponential in D many
combinations of them and especially if D
is large I don't want to actually get
this fairness by explicitly enumerated
all the possibilities so it turns out
that there is a very nice algorithmic
framework for solving these problems
that when you can make it work gives you
not just algorithms that are sort of
efficient in the theoretical sense but
they are practical in the empirical
sense as well and I'm not going to go
through these bullets but I'm going to
kind of tell you what the approach is so
the approach is to basically you know
write down this constrained optimization
problem and I'm gonna say some things
here that some people in the audience
will understand and others won't but you
have this constrain
optimization problem but the problem is
that there is the the model space first
of all might be very large so the the
space of models that the learners
choosing from might be like neural
networks it's gonna be you know it's not
gonna be something you want to like
exhaustively enumerate so the learner
has a very large space of models that
they're searching over as in vanilla
machine learning but now there's sort of
an exponential or even infinite number
of constraints on that model that come
from the fairness considerations okay
and so the first idea is to start with
this constrained optimization problem
and just sort of pass to its dual like
sort of classic convex or linear
programming duality and for those of you
that are familiar with that theory this
basically lets you go from a constrained
optimization problem to a two player
zero-sum game okay and it is to this two
player zero-sum game has an appealing
interpretation one player is the learner
and the learners action space if you
like in game theory terms they're pure
strategy space or like all the different
models in their class okay all neural
networks for example the other player
I'm going to call which is in food so
the learner is the primal player and the
dual player is what I'm going to call
suggestively the regulator so the
regulator basically is the way they're
to enforce the constraints and so how
does this game play out at a high level
at a high level the learner you know in
round one the learners it says okay I'm
gonna minimize the error on the data set
and they pick a neural network and then
the regulator you know looks at that and
says okay this neural network
discriminates badly against disabled
Hispanic women over age 55 making under
seventy-five thousand dollars a year fix
it and so this constraint gets added to
like the Lagrangian of the learner who
now has to essentially balance between
accuracy and fairness to disabled
Hispanic women over age 55 making less
than seventy five thousand dollars a
year and so this back and forth goes and
of course the worry about this back and
forth is that it will maybe never
converge or will converge only after an
infinite exponential or infinite number
of steps it turns out that if you can if
you can first of all figure out how
to let the so called best response of
each of these players if you can figure
out how to reduce it to a standard non
fare like a classification problem which
you often can that's kind of that's kind
of technical step one of this agenda and
to can figure out how to implement at
least one of the two players as what's
known as a no regret learning algorithm
which I'm not going to bother trying to
describe but if you can accomplish those
two steps then this back and forth
between the learner and the regulator
will actually converge rapidly and
because part of the reduction involves
you know an appeal to a standard
learning algorithm this gives an obvious
way to implement this game in real
algorithms right you basically at a high
level you've got you've used something
like back propagation in neural networks
as a subroutine it doesn't know about
fairness at all but the players are kind
of creating instances for training for
that algorithm that in encode the
fairness constraints and as long as one
of the players you can implement in this
no regret fashion this will provably
converge so so so basically you you know
it turns out that this but by the way
this this algorithmic framework is very
interesting and might be reminiscent to
some of you of ganz by the way where you
again you know set up a two player or a
game between a learner and you know and
a generator that's trying to fool the
learner and you know for those of you
that are familiar with that literature
it wouldn't surprise me if sometime in
the next couple of years using something
like this algorithmic framework somebody
actually kind of created a provably
convergent version of Ganz where you
actually would sort of say like okay you
know here is the goal of the
optimization here is a formal way of
going from that to like LP duality and
here's an efficient algorithm that
provable because the way Gant's are
usually done in practice now the setup
is very same but the execution of it is
very ad hoc you do sort of you know run
two players against each other and it
doesn't converge and you sort of pick
the point in you know along the
trajectory that looks the best but so
I'm gonna skip the rest of this but but
it turns out that this this framework is
good for
several different types of definitions
of fairness in which one or both players
might have a very large or exponential
number of constraints and this is what
lets you get closer to these notions of
individual fairness than these group
fairness notions and there's a lot of
very interesting work going on by in
this general area by by other groups as
well and let me stop there and take any
Q&A that there's time for the support
from the beta the size of the data set
you have about the minority group is
going to finish as financially as well
good good good good okay so I skipped
over the technical slide but if you
actually look at the constraints that
we're enforcing it incorporates that
right so what I mean by that is you know
suppose for instance you have sort of
unlimited conjunctions of these marginal
attributes that you want to enforce
fairness on and you want to get the
combination so so basically what we what
we really put a constraint on is the
amount of unfairness that group can
suffer times its mass in the
distribution okay so what this means is
that I'm because I'm looking at the
product of those things at the if a
group is a sizeable fraction of the
population I've really got to make its
unfairness equal to like the background
rate but if you get down to sort of
vanishingly small subgroups then I'm
allowed to be more unfair to them and
and they're sort of there's no way
around this in the definition for the
reason that you say right if I really
sort of ask that arbitrarily rare groups
have to be protected they might be so
rare that even in a very large sample
they're not represented in my dataset at
all there's not even a single member of
them and so you have to have just for
statistical estimation convergence
purposes you have to sort of only make
this promise to the groups that have
some minimum mass in the population or
the distribution but
then you can protect all of those and
there might be an exponential or
infinite number of those already it's a
good question yeah I think you worked
the back next my question is about
differential privacy specifically how
you convince companies to adopt the
French or privacy based solutions in
light of the following consideration if
you take a company like Facebook right
so they asked you you know to provide
your age you know of a whole bunch
integration of Excel and you could
refuse to do that right when you can you
can even fill those fields and look junk
but what Facebook can then do is ask
somebody who are your friends or just I
mean some random people who might happen
to know some information about you
asking them to maybe guess or provider
guess your age for instance okay and
then they can do anything they like put
this information and then say well we're
not actually using information coming
from this person or exact information
about this person we're just using some
guesses right and in this sense they are
kind of be evacuated differentially can
be vacuously differentially private and
yet you know they still have a lot of
information about you it can cause you
harm but you did not provide so let me
give a a high level answer I mean so you
know all of these algorithmic solutions
or maybe improvement as a more modest
word that I mentioned in this talk and
we discussed in the book you know
adoption of them by companies has to you
know macum Panisse want to say that
they're adopting these definitions and
figure out ways of gaming them you know
the opportunities for that are rife I
think you know so the companies either
need to decide that they're really
serious about this and they're not
trying to fake it and kind of you know
say that they're doing differential
privacy but having other means of
circumventing it or providing fairness
in one place but you know having it be
not consequential to their bottom line
for instance you know I think of those
as kind of social problems or maybe
regulatory problems and I do think we're
entering an era where regulatory forces
on these companies are going to have
much more teeth than they have in the
past you might have been making a more
technical point about differential
privacy which I think we did I think I
if I follow what you're saying an even
better example of where differential
privacy kind of doesn't promise you
anything even though you might think
that it does some of you might have
heard about these recent uses of
genealogical gene sequencing websites to
solve cold case murders okay so in
particular the Golden State Killer that
was active in the 1980s I think was a
serial murderer and rapist and was never
discovered was they know they didn't
know he was they had DNA from multiple
sites of this individual but you know
that he didn't they that this the DNA
didn't match any criminal genetic
database and and so this you know this
was like 30 40 years ago but now have
cropped these you know sites like
23andme where you can get your your your
gene you know gene sequenced and you can
upload them to these sites that let you
find your distant relatives and other
you know dark secrets about your past
that you never wanted to know you've
probably seen articles like this and so
some a particularly like a retired
detective basically said I'm I'm gonna
unfreeze some of the Golden State
killer's DNA and uploaded it to one of
these data these services and they
immediately found like several cousins
of the Golden State killer and by and
because these people are trying to find
their relatives and are saying who they
are and where they live suddenly they
they knew you know here are cousins of
the Golden State killers and they live
in this area
and this very quickly like within a
matter of weeks led them to the Golden
State killer who turned out to have been
a former Sacramento police officer
during the period that they were active
okay so even if you protected these
geological databases with differential
privacy the Golden State killer didn't
contribute their DNA to these databases
yet these databases basically you know
revealed him and the problem with DNA is
that even though we might think of our
DNA or genetic sequences as our private
data the problem is is you share a lot
of that
with your relatives and if your
relatives decide for instance to reveal
that data it compromises you in a way
the differential privacy and no notion
of privacy can possibly protect if we're
going to allow data analysis of any kind
at all
we have time for another one notions of
grouping and individual fairness there's
something that also looks at the two of
them so in the case of group fairness
I'm worried that you know we create
algorithms and we make them broadly
available and then we get into cases
where for the individual could be that
you know a disabled female um not only
is she left out but no matter how many
times she tries she never sees success
because everybody is using the same
algorithm and whereas if you had just
even a random probability of success
there's some probability that you
succeed and that success adds more to it
is there some sort of notion of an
amortized individual fairness yeah in
fact this yeah you know this slide
average individual fairness I'm not sure
if it's getting at the same idea you are
but it's basically saying like well if
there's sort of multiple decisions that
are going to be made about you across
your lifetime you know like what college
you get into whether you get a loan what
criminal sentence he received after
that's enough I could ask for a
different type of individual fairness
that doesn't say that on each one of
those decisions you are V you are
treated fairly but sort of that you know
your mistreatment across all of those
decisions is sort of roughly the same as
anyone elses and so this sort of same
algorithmic framework can be used for
that kind of fairness but I think
there's another point that maybe you're
getting at that this is not a solution
to which is that in an era of
algorithmic decision making you know so
one of the things we've say in the book
is like look discrimination in decision
making is not new to society because of
algorithms right you know there were
racist loan officers and are racist loan
officers for you know time immemorial
but at least like before algorithmic
decision making if you felt like you got
rejected for racial reasons
by one loan officer you could always go
and try others and hope that there would
be a different decision I think you're
right that one thing that's special
about algorithmic decision-making is
that it happens at scale and so for
instance I think I now believe that you
know conditioned on your being rejected
by one bank for a loan the chances that
you'll be rejected by all of them are
extremely high because they're all you
know using the same credit scoring
agencies they might you know and and
even if they even if they developed
their own algorithm right you know
machine learning people like to think
like oh you know their algorithms are
unique they're really proprietary etc
but you know it's like really the date
if you have if you have informative
features about what you're trying to
predict and enough data then you know to
a first approximation we're going to
arrive at similar models even if we have
different data sets and different like
you know details of our methodology and
I think that that aspect of scale and
uniformity of decision is a problem and
you know people it's sort of I haven't I
don't think I've said anything here
about fixes for that problem that you
can imagine you know kind of obvious
ones that include for instance the
requirement of a certain amount of
exploration regardless of what model
you're currently deploying so when you
talked about like the exponential number
of yeah it's really exponential only in
the number of attributes right because
of course you have like the number
constraints I you know for this there's
sort of D attributes that I want to
protect and I want to protect all
combinations of them that would be
exponential indeed no but you you need
like but but but in order to sort of I
mean to say it kind of very technically
if I have an exponential number of
constraints the amount of data that I
need to you know make sure that my
in-sample and out-of-sample fairness
will be the same as only logarithmic in
the number of constraints so it's
basically linear and D again yeah which
might take anymore about that top line
thank you everybody
[Applause]